[Music]
Hi everyone, I'm Will Brown. I'm at
Primeelect. Uh today I want to talk
about training agentic reasoners. Um,
just kind of as a very high level
overview, I think a lot of people here
are really excited about reasoning and a
lot of people here are really excited
about agents. But I feel like a lot of
the conversations between these two
topics are kind of like different where
people are like, "Oh, reasoning is this
one thing and agents are this other
thing." And the considerations of like
reasoning are very different from the
considerations of building agents. And I
think the high level thesis of this talk
is like no, they're kind of the same
thing. Um, and you'll see why as we get
into it. Um, first just to start like RL
kind of works now. Um, I think for a
long time people were like, "Oh, is that
our going to work? Is it not going to
work? How hard is it going to be?" Um,
and like DeepSeek, I think, took a lot
of people by surprise for many reasons
like the costs or whatever and like how
good it is compared to the open models
to the closed the big labs as well as
just it being fully open. Um, but I
think it was also just that it was RL
applied at scale working with
surprisingly few tweaks needed where you
just like have a good setup, you have a
good signal, you have a model that is
good enough to do some learning and you
see this curve where doing more RL
results in the model getting better. Um,
and it's also kind of how everyone else
is doing it. Like this is what the big
labs are really banking on to drive the
next iterations of progress. The 03
release is the one that OpenAI is really
excited about, not GBT 4.5. Like they
stopped serving the big pre-trained
model via API, but they have continued
to really double down on the scaling
direction of doing more and more
reinforcement learning and spending more
compute on reinforcement learning once
you have the right setup to enable
progress. And 03 to me is like a very
naturally agentic model. It the chat GBT
version has all these tools. The kind of
selling point of it is not just that
it's smarter. It's that it's really good
at using lots of tools in agentic task
settings to solve harder problems that
involve interacting with complex
systems. And that is kind of really the
selling point of all of this is that
like the more complex your system, the
more things can go wrong, the more that
like a generic LM API is going to be
brittle and go off the rails after a
certain number of steps. And RL is kind
of the way around it. It's the trick you
can do to take the system that kind of
works, maybe it works on small scales,
but as you go harder, it starts going
off the rails and train the model to be
better at that thing. Um, and so this is
a recipe that is still kind of like a
research topic that people are not fully
sure like the best way to do it,
especially outside of the big labs, but
it clearly is moving in a direction
where it's becoming more and more
reliable, more and more accessible, and
the sort of thing that I think would be
silly to disregard as a potential like
key piece of the future of agentic
software and agentic applications. Uh,
but it's also complicated. So on the
left here, this is the like architecture
diagram of Veril, which is kind of the
most popular software people use in the
research world for writing papers to uh
do RL. So if you want to like take a
model and go do RL, Verl kind of expects
that you understand all of this. Um on
the left we have uh uh the right we have
gpo as presented in the original
deepseek math paper back from early
2024. And like there's a lot of pieces
here. a lot of like complicated steps
going on that I think a lot of people
who are used to thinking about APIs,
used to thinking about building agents
kind of like are hoping they don't have
to worry about it. Um, and are hoping
that like you can just set it aside and
like something else will work and we'll
just use the APIs and it'll all be
great. And I think the reality is like
somewhere in the middle where like I
think it doesn't need to be this
complicated, but I think you also kind
of do have to be aware of it if your
goal is really like building the most
performant agents. Not necessarily just
like today you need to know about it,
but as a piece of the toolkit to
potentially make really powerful agentic
software. I think the people who are
willing to do this and take the best
open models and really RL them for their
tasks and can figure out how to do that
well are going to have a huge advantage.
And that's the kind of thing that also
allows you to like build a moat beyond
just like being a wrapper API and
towards something where it's like, oh, I
actually have my own model now. But not
everyone can be a big lab. And so we
kind of need to meet in the middle
somewhere of like, okay, how do we make
this a thing that starts to become
feasible for startups, for individual
researchers to actually do? Uh, and like
at what scale does this become like
feasible? Um, and so agents are like the
type of product that everyone's excited
about. We all like love cloud code and
Devon and Manis and uh 03 and deep
research and like these are the sorts of
products that are really capturing
people's attention. Um they're products
that in their current iteration happen
to work kind of because the models that
are being used have like been RL to
basically do these kinds of things. Um,
like Claude is a very good coding agent
probably because it has been RL on a lot
of code. And so it's like not very
surprising that if you plug Claude into
essentially a while loop with some
tools, it's like quite good at doing
these things because it's basically most
likely been trained in almost that exact
setting. Um same for things like 03 like
it can do geogesser and whatever because
whether it's literally geoger or
something close to it they have talked
about training it to do this image
cropping trick like that's a a technique
that it didn't just know how to do out
of the box they said hey let's give it
these tools to do that and use
reinforcement learning to train it to do
that and so that is kind of the recipe
that we have seen coming from the big
labs as if you want a powerful agent
that can do a certain type of task you
can use reinforcement learning to train
it to do that task better Um and so
these are kind of the same thing
actually like building an agent. Uh the
pieces of making an agent in terms of
the harness, the environment, the tools
and the iteration is essentially the
same conceptual framing as canonical
reinforcement learning in the sense of
policies, actions, states, rewards,
transition probabilities. Um, and I
think the more that we start to view
agents as this umbrella, which is not
just about static chaining of API calls,
but as this interaction loop with
evaluations,
that framing really is the way to think
about RL, which is you build a system
where a thing is interacting with an
environment and you have some way of
evaluating how good it's doing. And RL
is simply an algorithm to improve based
on the scores of these evaluations.
And if you're building agents and you're
tuning your prompt and you're fiddling
with your harnesses, this is kind of
like doing RL by hand. What you're doing
is you're saying like, okay, currently
my evals are saying this. Let's make
sure the eval are like capturing what I
want. Let's look at the data. Let's see
if the data matches what my evals are
saying. And then, oh, let's try a new
prompt. Let's try giving it a new tool.
Um, let's try uh switching out the
model. um like this is the process which
is also being targeted by reinforcement
learning in the general sense beyond
individual algorithms um about these
algorithms like there's a few of them
that are mo very important all of them
have like different implementation
details but in general the idea is you
have a bunch of tasks like versions of
your problem which are essentially
prompts you have rollouts which are just
completions potentially involving many
steps of interactions but like one
sequence of stuff happening and then you
have evaluations potentially interly
throughout or at the end of the sequence
and what you're estimating is the
advantage. The advantage here is the
idea that uh sometimes your model will
be be better than others. Like these uh
LMs are all uh non-deterministic. You
have temperature above zero. You have
different things happen in different uh
rolls of the dice. Um and this uh
forking process of saying like okay this
time it did better than that time. Why
was it different? RL is really about
saying like okay uh this is the actual
thing that changed that resulted in the
reward being better the eval being
better this is the token at which I went
down the good path versus the bad path
um and whether you're doing PO or GRPO
um like this is the mechanism by which
you get the signal of like you have some
things that sometimes went better
sometimes went worse now you can kind of
uh very surgically have the model learn
to do more of the good stuff without
changing too much overall. I think this
is also kind of maybe a reason why DPO I
think people were hoping DPO would like
really work well. In my view, DPO does
not necessarily have this like fine
grain advantage estimate. Like it's not
really clear just from like a full good
completion and a full bad completion
where you're really getting the signal
about these complex branching processes.
Uh PO has this but it's also very
expensive. GRPO I think has taken a lot
of people kind of uh by storm in terms
of like being a very nice like middle
ground where it's more computationally
efficient. It's like simple to
implement. Um but also it does have this
kind of forking process that comes just
from sampling. Um there's also just too
many papers. So like I think a lot of
people just see a new paper every day
and are like do I have to read this one?
Um and I feel that too.
I think it's difficult to know upfront
like which of these are going to be
important, which of them are just going
to be like noise, especially because
lots of them have very sensationalist
titles like oh Quen doesn't work. Um or
like or everyone everything only works
with Quen is like kind of true, but like
there's also more to the story than
that. And I think there's like different
implementation details of like oh if you
change the loss function like this in
this experiment then it works. And I
think for most people it is best to just
like kind of set this aside and to not
get too caught up in the individual
details of individual experiments and
individual papers and kind of think more
holistically about what is the process
of reinforcement learning doing? Um what
implementation details am I willing to
kind of leave to other people to figure
out and eventually come to me with like
software that like has the the knob set
correctly. Um and which pieces are
actually important for solving the
problems I care about. Um, and so for a
lot of people, I think the things that
are going to be really interesting, um,
are things that are relating to actual
software, to actual problems that they
want to solve in the world. And agents,
I think, are kind of the instantiation
of that where this makes sense. And the
thing that makes an agent an agent is
tools. Uh, the ability to interact with
an environment, with a system. A lot of
people here are like very excited about
MCP at the conference. Like MCP is just
tools. MCP is about giving your LM the
ability to like interact with stuff to
go solve problems that involve changing
files, making requests, uh, editing
code, running code. Um, and so I think
these are the papers that I get excited
about because there feel like like
there's parts of the puzzle that are not
fully solved yet of like what's the
right way to do all of this. Like
there's still some open questions. Um,
but I think those are getting kind of
refined. We're starting to see more and
more, but like a lot of the code, the
tools we have out in the wild to like go
do this. Like if you want to like go
play around with RL, most code bases are
like very set up for like either code
and math tasks or things that are quite
similar to that. This is kind of my
fault. Um I had a a snippet go viral
that was like here's how you do RL on
like GSMK, which is like a kind of easy
math data set. Um, and then I think I've
seen a lot of people like stick with
this as like, oh, we're gonna RL on
math. And I like this is also just like
math is easy to evaluate. Um, and I
think people are eval
parallel to this about like how to build
a good eval. Um, and so I think a lot of
researchers gravitate towards things
that like look like the benchmarks that
are also really easy to eval because
there's like a very clear signal of
like, okay, this thing is like right,
this thing is wrong. Good. Okay, we're
doing RL. Um but like real world tasks
are messier than that. Um we are not
going to like get great software systems
just by like hill climbing on whatever
question answer benchmark is popular
today. Um what we're going to do is
we're going to have to do is start
thinking about like the actual systems
at hand and the challenges that emerge
when we're trying to design these
rewards. And so like reward hacking is
like a real thing. Um I think this is
one of the lessons that like Rall works
but also it's not like always going to
work. There are things that can go
wrong. And to me, reward hacking is
really a message about the difficulty of
building good evals. Like uh what you
really want with an eval is for it to be
easier for your model to do the task
than to hack the eval. You want to build
a reward signal that actually captures
what you care about where uh gaming it
is like more difficult than not gaming
it. If you can if the model can learn to
do the task directly just by doing what
you want it to do uh in the spirit of
the task then like that is what will
happen. It will flow in the path of
least resistance. This is like models
just want to learn but they want to
learn to do better on reward signals and
so your reward signals have to point in
the direction of the thing you actually
care about. Um otherwise like models
will find cheats. Um, and I think
thinking about these things in
combination kind of points a little bit
towards a direction that I think is
going to be very promising. And there's
some very early signs that like this
actually can work. Um, which is like
when R1 came out, I was kind of like
speculating like what's next? What are
the things that are going to unlock this
sort of technique being used more
generally? Um, and you people talk a lot
about like generator verifier gaps, like
what are the differences between like
solving a problem versus checking if you
have a solution. And a lot of problems
like are much easier to check than
solve. But this isn't like a binary
thing. This is a spectrum of how
difficult is it to verify a thing. But
um there's some kind of signs that you
kind of can do evaluations on more
ambiguous tasks by just breaking them
down into smaller pieces and by using
LMS as sub routines in your evaluations
like LM judge on steroids where maybe
you want to actually like train a
specialized LM who is really good at
doing these fine grain evaluations. I
like using the term rubric as a
conceptual general umbrella around
reward models, reward functions, alm as
judge setups, like the criteria on which
you are evaluating a thing. There's a
cool paper from deepseek that I was
thought found very exciting when it came
out a couple months ago about like how
to train reward models that like
generate these rubrics on the fly. There
was a paper very recently that does this
for creative writing and kind of found
that like yes, you actually can train
reward models that will come up with
nuanced fine-rain evaluation criteria
for a task on the fly given the actual
problem. And this gives you something
that results in a very like fine grain
score that allows you to actually do RL
and like keep getting better. Um, and I
think like this is an area that I'm
really excited about to keep watching.
Um, but also like multi-turn. Multi-turn
is probably where we're headed. We want
to do a jetic search. We want to do tool
calls, software, games, long horizon
planning, computer use, memory, scaling
on tool calls let you solve harder
problems. Um, and so how do we actually
like do this? What's the uh way to go
about building multi- aent or multi-turn
agentic systems to do and that we can
use RL with? Um, and I think the
conceptual pieces here are environments
are basically harnesses, rewards are
basically eval tasks are just prompts,
and your policy in the RL sense
hopefully should just be as simple as
like an LM API. The I think the
programming interface that makes sense
for a lot of people is to have an API
that you're writing code as if it's just
a normal agent in a loop, but then this
is a thing that you can use to go do RL.
And so that's what I've been building
over the past couple months. Um, I
maintain a repo called verifiers. Um
it's finally uh on pip uh out in the
world. You can just install it, but it's
been a long time coming. Um and what it
really is is a toolkit of these pieces
to make it so that building an agent
that you can actually train with RL
feels just like building an agent. Um,
so the interaction protocol here is like
quite simple like this is the entire
roll out function on the left of like
what happens in the code when you're
running an agent to do RL which is that
you kind of set up some initial state
stuff have a while loop for is it done
yet? If it's not done do a turn and the
thing you're passing here is a client
object that's just an OpenAI compatible
API. And I think this is the kind of
interface that you really want if you
want people to be able to go from their
agent applications to something that's
trainable to something they can use with
RL. Um it's been a lot of fun thinking
about like what are the abstractions?
What are the pieces here? And so like
there's things like parsers and rubrics
that I think are like nice building
blocks that you sometimes want to use.
You can also like not use them if you
don't want to. But like I tried to make
it fun and user friendly. Um the other
day I like was like let's train a Wordle
agent. I think this was like a fun
little toy problem where it's like it's
not that hard of like a game for us as
humans, but like it's actually like kind
of tricky to get your code to be this
sort of thing where you have this like
multi-turn interaction protocol that you
actually can do learning with. Um, but
now it's like much easier. like the code
to do these things is like quite simple
and the reward functions can kind of be
relatively simple for this sort of setup
where it's like okay you want to reward
it for like uh solving the thing
eventually but also like give it more
rewards for doing it in less turns and
like this is a 7B model like works
reasonably well but one of the reasons
it works um which I'll talk about in a
sec is uh SF warm-up as a way of kind of
lowering the barrier of entry like this
the code as it is is very much set up so
that like your environments for RL are
also just like synthetic data loops or
evals where you can plug in claude or
deepseek or open AAI and like test. So
you don't have to like do RL to debug.
You can like debug with an API in terms
of seeing is this a good eval? Is this a
good reward once you're kind of
comfortable with it you can like use
whatever API you like that you are
allowed to use and make synthetic data
do some SFT on it and now you can start
doing RL and this like helps a lot with
small models. Um, I think there's a lot
of efficiency challenges that are like
I've been kind of hard at work trying to
solve in terms of like having all of
your computation be utilized
effectively, having everything be like
fully async so you don't have to worry
about like batching. Um, and that your
trainer and your inference can kind of
go at the same time. You can be like a
little bit off policy. Um, a lot of
engineering that I'm hoping like if you
want to worry about that, great. Dig
into it, fork the repo, mess with
things. If you don't want to, you
shouldn't have to. Um, and like the idea
here is that this should become
something that more people are trying
out, more people are having fun with
with exploring and getting a feel for
it. Um, because if it's going to be a
thing we have to worry about, if this is
the future of building better agent
models uh for your applications, like
now's a good time to start. Um, and so
this stuff is set up so you can like on
a couple GPUs like uh do a lot of
interesting research. Like the barrier
of entry is like much lower now than it
used to be. Um, I have a lot of fun
doing this on like a couple GPUs. Uh, we
sell GPUs by the way. Um, thanks
everybody. Uh, I don't think we have
time for questions, but uh, yeah.
[Music]